threaten me again and I'll have you thrown into
the sea you might be disappointed in the results
storms come and go the big fish eat the little
fish and I keep on paddling but remember the
Queen mustn't know oh the Queen mustn't know I
love conversations that begin this way I plan to
marry Princess Myrcella off to Theon Greyjoy Theon
Greyjoy and it seems the grand maester has found
his way into a black cell well played my lord
hand power resides where men believe it resides
it's a trick a shadow on the wall and a very
small man can cast a very large shadow we could
throw books at his men we don't have that many
books we don't have that many men either what do
we have pig [__] they say Stannis never smiles
I'll get them a red slime from ear to ear imagine
Stannis's terror I am trying you're an intelligent
man I'd like to think I'm an intelligent man no no
one disputes that my lord not even the multitudes
who despise you I wish we could converse as two
honest intelligent men I wish we could - where's
the god of tits and wine in the Summer Isles they
worship the fertility goddess with 16 teats you
should sell there immediately Oh Drake is that
it is that it nice touch as if you don't know the
name of every boy in town I'm not entirely sure of
what you're suggesting I'm entirely sure you're
entirely sure what I'm suggesting the map you
asked for and to provide escape if necessary not
escaping changes it sounds on the captain of the
ship and if the ship goes down I go with her that
is good to hear there aren't sure many captains
say the same while their ship is afloat I hope
we might speak in confidence always in confidence
they have hated magic and all those who practice
but you can see why I was eager to aid in your
fight against Stannis and his red priestess
a symbolic revenge of sorts yes mmm I feel
the need for actual revenge against the actual
person who tried to have me killed which will
require a degree of influence which you do not
possess do you know what it's like to stuff your
[__] through one of those airholes no I only
know what it's like to pick up your [__] and
throw it overboard your Nick the spider the master
of whisperers imp half-man you have your father's
instincts for politics and you have compassion
compassion I killed my lover with my bare hands
I shot my own father with a crossbow I never
said you were perfect there's a book yes best
be careful you might accidentally consume some
solid food people follow leaders and they will
never follow us they find us repulsive I find us
repulsive let's go for a walk no how many dwarves
are there in the world I will not be of any use
to Daenerys Targaryen if I lose my mind I can't
remember the last face I saw that wasn't yours
it's perfectly good face I'm losing my mind if
anyone recognizes you you'll lose more than that
look we are thousands of miles from Westeros what
am I one more drunk dwarf we should keep moving
good looks stopping the spread of greyscale with
prayer we'd have better luck dancing away the
plate so badly needed Apple she bought the way
macGruber it's even better luck to suck a Dwarfs
[__] curious hair very bang I need to speak
to someone with hair a grand old city choking on
violence corruption and deceit who could possibly
have any experience managing such a massive
ungainly Beast I did miss you though I know
you walk like a rich person you've spent a lot of
time studying the way rich people walk you walk
as they're the paving stones with your personal
property it's to steal from people like you and
have it's a boy it's a good thing you're not a
boy anymore because you have no [__] a o ha Rosa
she says she wants to eat her baby does he have
Valyria categories if I lost
my [__] I drink all the time
meaning no offense he makes forth jokes
I make unique jokes I do not make dwarf
jokes you think them next time I have an idea
like that punch me in the face my own recent
experience with slavery has taught me the
horrors of that institution how many days we
were safe long enough to know not long enough
to understand who made a pact with fanatics I
did and it worked if you shaved your beard with
a straight razor you'd say the razor work that
doesn't mean it won't cut your throat spoken
like a man who has never had to shave I can't
go off on a secret mission in the company
of the most famous dwarf in the city Paris
the most famous dwarf in the world
who's that for John snap did you read it it's a
sealed scroll for the King in the north what's
it say nothing good you should consider yourself
lucky least your balls won't freeze off you take
great defensive dwarf jokes but love telling
you new jerks why is that because I have balls
you don't John and Daenerys don't want to listen
to lonely old men not that old not as old as him